recommendations that will bring more
options and more flexibility to
healthcare providers
you know it could absolutely allow for
expanded availability a vaccine
you know in some temporary clinics some
pop-up mobile sites
and those locations that do not have
cold storage
capacity the overall increased vaccine
supply creates greater opportunity for
people to get
vaccinated we also recognize some
individuals may have a preference for a
single dose vaccine
so those who do not want to return for a
second dose or who would have difficulty
returning for a second dose
we understand that still as a physician
i strongly urge everyone in america to
get the first vaccine
that is available to you when it is your
turn
if people want to opt for one vaccine
over another you know they may have to
wait
time is of the essence getting
vaccinated saves lives
and no doubt communities across the
country have been devastated by this
pandemic
the vaccines and vaccinations are a
critical tool in bringing this
unprecedented pandemic to an end
and now we have three and so for that in
addition to the scientists i want to
thank all of the clinical trial
participants for their contributions to
scientific discovery
you know for this for this vaccination
campaign to be successful
vaccines will have to reach everyone and
so kudos to those states and
jurisdictions who are already working
closely
with trusted leaders in the hardest hit
communities
to ensure fair and equitable access to
vaccinations
this is best practice so again
all three vaccines have been proven safe
highly effective
at preventing severe disease
hospitalization and death from kova 19
after full immunity and if i could leave
people with one message it is this
get vaccinated but the first vaccine
available to you
protect yourself your family and your
community from coven 19.
and with that i'll turn it over to you
jeff well thank you dr nina smith
i'll provide an update on our planning
logistics
and distribution of the recently
authorized johnson johnson
vaccine before we open it up for
questions
the last several weeks we've been
working with governors
state and local health officials and
pharmacies and community health centers
to ensure we were ready to roll out the
j j vaccine
immediately after fda approval and cdc
recommendations starting yesterday we
began
executing on our plans by distributing
3.9 million doses of johnson and johnson
to states tribes and territories and
also to pharmacies and community health
centers
johnson and johnson's doses will be
delivered as early as tomorrow
we're allocating the j j vaccine the
exact same way
we allocate pfizer and modernist vaccine
proportional to a state tribe or
territories population
so for example if a state represents two
percent
of the u.s population it receives
approximately two percent of the pfizer
allocation
two percent of the modern allocation and
will now
receive two percent of the j j
allocation
that is made to states tribes and
territories
we have directed states to manage
distribution of all three vaccines in a
fair and equitable way
and we will continue to monitor that
closely
as part of that work the cdc is tracking
distribution of vaccines
across a range of equity metrics
including zip codes
and social vulnerability index data
we have three very effective vaccines in
all communities
should have equitable and even access to
each vaccine
as to the expected supply of johnson
johnson vaccine
this week will distribute 3.9 million
doses
that is the entirety of johnson and
johnson's current inventory
we're getting these doses out the door
right away
to ensure vaccines get into arms as
quickly as possible
jnj has communicated that the supply
will be limited for the next couple of
weeks
following this initial distribution of
nearly 4 million doses
the company then expects to deliver
approximately 16 million additional
doses
by the end of march however
as we have discussed with governors and
their teams
and with federal partners we know that j
j
distribution and delivery will be uneven
across these early weeks in march and
the company expects the delivery to be
predominantly in the back half
of the month
overall in the jnj vaccine we've done
the planning
we have the distribution channels in
place
and we're getting doses out the door as
quickly as possible to get
shots in arms so we're focused on
execution
and that includes the important work of
ensuring that we continue
to increase overall vaccine supply
increase the number of vaccinators
and increase the number of places
americans can get vaccinated
next i want to provide an update on the
pace of doses being administered
as you can see on our weekly vaccination
report
the current seven-day average is 1.7
million
shots per day given that the first
couple of days in this seven-day period
included the storm impacts 1.7 million
actually
understates the current pace over the
weekend we experience
new record levels of daily vaccinations
that said we have much more to do on all
fronts
and our war on this pandemic
there is a path out of this pandemic but
how quickly we exit this crisis depends
on all of us
that's why i encourage everyone to take
the advice of doctors wilinsky
fauci and nunes smith follow the public
health guidance
get vaccinated when it's your turn and
continue to wear mass
and social distance to protect yourself
and your fellow americans
we will continue doing everything we can
as a federal government to defeat this
virus
but it will take all of us stepping up
to do our part
with that let's open it up to questions
great and a reminder to please keep your
questions to one question only
first up we'll go to elizabeth wise at
usa today
hi thank you so much for taking my
question um you didn't say how many
doses are being shipped this week
i think usually you've had that uh my
question however
is so appointment systems seem to be the
rate limiting factor for getting people
vaccinated in a lot of the country and
in some cases this is frustrating people
who aren't coming back because
they couldn't get through as states move
into phase 1b and 1c and we get
tens of millions of more americans who
are eligible how is this system going to
cope and what are you doing
to strengthen it so the number of doses
is 3.9 million so that was the entire
j j inventory and all of those doses are
being shipped
this week you know i i i think
scheduling
an appointment is too difficult remains
too difficult in too many places you
know in some states or in some locales
things have gotten better the pharmacy
systems are often
better at scheduling and appointments
but overall
too many americans are are suffering
frustration
taking up way too much time to schedule
an appointment
and we have addressed
some of those root causes as we've
increased the vaccine supply as we put
more vaccinators in the field as we've
increased the number of places
but now we really need to make sure the
systems can handle
not only the current demand but the
projected demand for people being
vaccinated so we're working with states
to improve their health
sites so that they can handle this
capacity
we're also looking at lower tech
solutions that the federal government
might be able to provide whether those
are call centers
or people to help navigate the system so
i think overall scheduling
remains for far too many people too
frustrating
and we need to make it better
next question next we'll go to william
joy with wfaa
dallas yeah
thank you for taking my question so this
has to do with equity for either dr
nunez smith or
jeff so at least here in in dallas fort
worth
the gap between vaccinations in affluent
zip codes
versus underserved zip codes is actually
getting worse so
how specifically are you grading
yourself when it comes to equity
and what's that grade right now dr
dr smith yeah so thanks for the question
we're absolutely
percent committed to equitable uh
vaccine
access and you know the statistics that
you share
are very concerning to us we know that
we still have a challenge in terms of
in terms of data the data quality are
not exactly where we'd like them to
be as far as race ethnicity but even the
data that we have do suggest
uh this pattern you know we are already
in the
in the federal programs prioritizing um
equity
we have been committed to this from the
very beginning in the launch of those
programs
using metrics such as the cdc's social
vulnerability indexed out guide where
resources should go
um you know ultimately we do believe
that people should be vaccinated
um at the rates different groups should
be vaccinated at the rates in their
population and that's
that's our target and our goal we're
already working
closely with states to provide technical
assistance
um where needed we will continue to do
so
i think dr nunes captured it well i will
add that the president
has been crystal clear that as important
as speed inefficiency
in vaccinations equity and fairness
are as important and we need to make
sure that we execute on a strategy that
ensures equity
and fairness
great next question we'll go to lord
garrett
sorry had a moment of unmuting thank you
very much
uh yes i have a question regarding the
variance and this would go to both
doctors fauci and wilinsky we have this
new new york variant that jumped from
0.2 percent of identified viruses in
early november to now about 28
in new york and it seems to have arisen
in an hiv aids patient
um indicating the possibility that we
could see variants arising in highly
immunosuppressed individuals
and they're warning that it may be
colonizing um
nasal cells with very high like 10-fold
affinity for ace-two receptors
and that's a site pretty privileged in
terms of igg neutralizing antibodies
um so i wonder my question is how
worried should we be about this
particular variant
and is it possible that vaccinated
and covered surviving individuals who
have
neutralizing antibodies in their blood
systems could still
harbor and colonize and transmit from
their noses
to other individuals thank you let's
start with dr fauci then we'll go to dr
wolinski dr fauci
well we certainly are taking the new
york uh
variant the 526 very seriously
lori um you know as as you know it
it started off in what is likely in the
washington heights
section and then has gone through
multiple boroughs and is now
gaining work done by david ho
has shown that we have to really keep an
eye on that for its ability to evade
both
monoclonal antibody and to a certain
extent um
the vaccine induced anybody so it's
something we take
very very seriously the idea about the
accessibility of antibody
to the nasopharynx i mean that's
obviously a good point
it's a theoretical but it can be a real
issue
so i'm sure that's going to be something
that is going to be looked at and
studied
about the degree of not only the viral
load but also the persistence of the
viral load
in the nasal pharynx so good points
all unknown right now but something that
we're going to be looking at very
carefully
dr wolinski anything to add there
i would just say we know that um early
studies actually showed that these
variants could emerge in a single post
in a single immunocompromised host as
well um
and and it's our reasons to decrease
circulating virus
everywhere but in the community as well
as in individuals
i think is important because we often
get asked a question that's a reasonable
question
should people who are immunocompromised
get vaccinated
and the answer is absolutely yes
absolutely yes because that's not only
important for them for their own health
but that could be the breeding ground of
the ever
the the emergence of a variance for the
simple reason
that if you don't clear the virus
rapidly you're going to have
immunological
selection within a given individual and
as laurie said correctly that was
probably how all this started with 526.
next question we'll go to jeremy diamond
at cnn
hey thanks for uh taking the question um
sorry let me just mute this tv here
apologies i'm hoping you could address
some of the concerns
uh that the more easily deployable
nature of the johnson johnson vaccine
will make it the go-to vaccine for
marginalized and harder-to-reach
communities i know you guys have said
that
you know that's something that you're
monitoring and you want states to
distribute these shots equitably
but beyond monitoring what more can the
administration do
to not only avoid this perception that
you know you have different vaccines for
different classes of americans
but also to make sure that you're
getting the most bang for your buck from
an epidemiological perspective
given the limited supply doctor
absolutely thank you for the for the
question um so you know
we shouldn't lose sight of the very good
news that we have we have three
authorized uh vaccines that's tremendous
um we do expect that they be distributed
evenly for all uh communities to benefit
um there are clinical benefits to to j j
that we talked about
um briefly in terms of uh the coal
storage capacity
the single dose um that might make it
very useful for healthcare providers in
their toolkit as they're thinking about
things like
um like some pop-ups but overall you
know we do
think that the the distribution again
should be should be even
um across communities so importantly
providing
that guidance um up front we are
modeling that within the federal
programs
um and then you know as we said we will
be tracking biometrics such as zip code
and social vulnerability um to see where
vaccines are going and should certain
vaccines go consistently to certain
communities
we will be able to intervene and you
know we're here to provide
support and technical assistance to
pivot um
and and intervene and correct if and
when needed
last question we'll go to zeke miller at
the associated press
uh thank you all for getting the call um
two minutes first just to follow up on
what dr nunes smith just said what would
that intervention look like would you
that
be a reduction in the state's allocation
and then uh more broadly uh for doctors
mulinsky dr fauci
uh what uh is the current timetable in
terms of federal guidance
on what people who have been vaccinated
uh can and shouldn't do in this moment
is it safe for them to go out to dinner
right now
can they start to travel and are you
worried that the delay in getting that
sort of guidance is
having a downward pressure on demand
so zeke i'll go first here and then over
to
the doctors you know if we if we were to
see that vaccines were going to certain
communities we will
take action as dr nunes smith said
to ensure supply is distributed evenly
and first actions would include
obviously the communication
of our standards and our insistence that
people adhere to the standards
and then we would begin by providing
technical assistance to the
state or other providers second question
over to you dr fauci
yes uh so this is something that the
team the medical team
talks about all the time ultimately the
cdc
will be coming out within a reasonable
period of time i'll
let rochelle give you that time frame in
a moment
but you know i have been asked and have
said publicly
that you know as we get more and more
people vaccinated the
logical question that was just asked by
zeke is an important question
and that is what happens if you get um
doubly vaccinated people with the with
the uh
pfizer and moderna for example uh
members of family
people coming in like i use the example
of a
daughter coming in from out of town who
is doubly vaccinated
and a husband and wife doubly vaccinated
and maybe a next door
neighbor who you know are doubly
vaccinated small gatherings in the home
of people i think you can clearly feel
that the
risk the relative risk is so low that
you would not have to wear a mask that
you could have
a good social gathering within the home
beyond that
is going to be based on a combination of
data
a combination of modeling and a
combination of good
clinical common sense and the cdc is
working on that right now
and we'll all be together with a good
message i hopefully soon so rochelle why
don't you
take it from there yeah i don't have
much to add except to say we're actively
working on this guidance we're looking
forward to releasing it soon
um at the same time and i i would agree
with all the dr falchi
said at the same time i want to really
keep our eye on the fact that we
um we are in our cases are increasing
right now um slightly and but they are
and so you know the goal is not to sort
of open up travel
open up all of you know things because
um people
you know we're scaling up vaccination
the goal in those first hundred days
um has always been to sort of make sure
that we are in a
place to be out of this pandemic at
seven thousand cases per day
we're not in that place right now so
while we may have uh
you know guidance at the individual
level as dr falchi has suggested i think
we all need to keep our eye on the fact
that we're not out of the woods here yet
yeah
the environment of as i just mentioned
the setting
in a home of a small group of people
having dinner together all of whom are
vaccinated
is very different when you step out the
door and go into a society
that has 70 000 new infections per day
so amen to what dr wolenski just said
i want to thank everybody for joining
today we'll be back together on
wednesday
thank you
you
[Laughter]
you